تطور استهداف داخل الاراضي الروسيه في
موسكو تحديدا واعتراف الجانب الاوكراني
بهذا الاستهداف ما الذي يعني المقاربه
بدات اكثر وضوح الجانب الروسي يتحدث عن
عمليه عسكريه خاصه كان الجغرافيا جغرافيا
روسيا الاتحاديه ما قبل شهر شباط من العام
الماضي خارج اطار المعركه الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث عن حرب روسيه على
اوكرانيا في المقاربه الاوكرانيه بدات
الان اكثر وضوحا خاصه مع تعثر الهجوم او
المرحله التمهيديه من الهجوم المضاد فبدات
تبحث عن وسائل ضغط اضافيه قد لا تكون
فاعله من وجهه نظر عسكريه لكنها
ستلقي بظلالها في الابعاد الاخرى
الاسابيع محاوله الوصول الى قبه
لها الوصول الى قواعد عسكريه تقع الى
الشمال الى الجنوب الشرقي من روسيا الان
نتحدث عن
مسيرتين واحده على مقربه من وزاره الدفاع
في هذه الجراه الاوكرانيه المتتاليه
بالمسيرات على العاصمه الروسيه موسكو هل
برايك باستطاعه روسيا الرد عليها
ان توقفه لا تستطيع لانه مساحه واسعه جدا
تنطلق من مناطق متعدده
بمبرات متباينه متباعده بتوقيتات مختلفه
الرد ياتي بالقذف الروسي سواء بالعام 19
طائره مسيره في اودن بقصف البنيه التحتيه
ما تتعلق بالطاقه لكنه لا يرضع اذا ما
الفائده
من منظور عسكري يجب ان لا يرجع اوكرانيا
دوله تعيش حاله حرب فعليها وانا اتحدث من
منظور عسكري عليها ان تستخدم كافه الاوراق
التي بيدها صغيره ام كبيره تقييمك انت
للوضع وتاثير هذه العمليات التي تقوم بها
اوكرانيا يجب ان نميز ما بين مناطق دخلتها
القوات الروسيه
واثناء المعارك انسحبت منها وبالتالي انا
لا اضعها ضمن المناطق التي تم السيطره
عليها هذا اجريت بالامس قراءه استشرافيه
لحجم المساحه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا الان
وجدتها تنحصر ما بين 58 الف الى 62 الف
كيلو متر مربع لا تزال تحت السيطره
الروسيه بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم